soir thomas bamako qui semble avoir du
mal à digérer le départ de l'opération
barkan et la façon de faire
absolument le premier ministre malien a
profité de la tribune de l'assemblée
générale des nations unies à new york
pour délivrer un message fort à
destination de paris choquel maïga est
revenu donc sur la décision d' emmanuel
macron de réduire la présence militaire
dans le cadre de l'opération barkan
rappelez-vous le président français
avait annoncé au mois de juillet dernier
la fermeture de certaines bases et la
réduction des effectifs militaires
déployés qui pourrait passer de plus de
5000 aujourd'hui à 3000 à l'horizon 2023
et bien le premier ministre malien
dénonce de son côté un manque de
concertation et de consultation écoutez
le
le mali règle est que le principe de
consultation et de concertation qui doit
être la règle entre partenaires
privilégiés n'est pas été observé en
amant la décision du gouvernement fera
ce la nouvelle situation née de la fin
de barques en place à le mali devant le
fait accompli et l'exposant à 1,7 à une
espèce d'abandon en plein vol nous
conduit à explorer les voies et moyens
pour mieux assurer la sécurité de
manière autonome avec d'autres
partenaires le premier ministre malien
qui rejette aussi l'idée d'un
développement d'un sentiment anti
français au mali en état de fait qui est
pourtant relativement étayée par un
certain nombre de témoignages qui nous
arrive du mali depuis ces derniers mois
et thomas ce discours qui intervient en
tout cas au moment où la diplomatie
française s'inquiète du fait que bamako
se tourner vers d'autres partenaires
oui parce que la semaine dernière déjà à
new york lors d'un entretien entre jean
yves le drian et sergueï lavrov le
dossier malien avait déjà été abordées
paris avait fixé une ligne rouge site
avons avertissant le chef de la
diplomatie russe des conséquences graves
de l'implication du groupe wagner au
mali une injonction à laquelle a répondu
sergueï lavrov c'était donc ce samedi
lors de sa conférence de presse au siège
des nations unies à new york
les autorités de transition
continue d'ailleurs cette lutte contre
le terrorisme et dans cette optique ils
se sont adressés à des compagnies
armées privées
parce que la france a si j'ai bien
compris décidé de réduire
significativement sa présence militaire
donc les autorités maliennes ont estimé
que leur force propre était insuffisante
sans aide extérieure et comme l'aide de
ceux qui aiment qui s'était engagé à
déraciner le
terrorisme donc bah du coup ils
s'adressent à des compagnies
militaires privées russes nous n'avons
rien à voir avec ça et cela ne concerne
que le gouvernement légitime ce qui est
considéré comme
les forces de transition légitime et
ceux qui proposent ce genre de service
sergueï lavrov a aussi expliqué qu'il
avait discuté de ce dossier avec le chef
de la diplomatie de l'union européenne
josette borel et ce dernier lui aurait
fait comprendre que l'afrique était en
quelque sorte un pré carré européen et
que la russie n'y avait donc n'avait
donc rien à y faire alors moscou de son
côté appelle à une concertation et un
travail conjoint dans le respect des
règles internationales mais comme l'a
répété cette semaine la semaine dernière
l'union européenne le recours par bamako
à des partenaires privés comme la
société wagner mènerait à une
reconsidération du déploiement européen
au mali merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington et pour